une des difficultés principales des
négociations de la COP15 ce sera de
savoir comment mesurer l'effet des
actions qui seront prises pour la
biodiversité
à l'université maguile rencontre
virtuelle ce soir organisée par l'équipe
d'Anjou Gonzales
[Musique]
au rendez-vous des membres des parties
d'une vingtaine de pays scientifiques
négociateurs on est le 27 octobre à 40
jours du début de la COP15 et il reste
beaucoup à faire
[Musique]
un regroupement international de près de
2500 experts en biodiversité ici on fait
tout pour que les représentants des pays
soient prêts à négocier pour décembre et
qu'il comprenne les enjeux scientifiques
[Musique]
pour comprendre leurs quelques jours
plus tôt on se penche avec un juke
Gonzales sur le document qui sera
négocié à Montréal le nouveau cadre
mondial pour la biodiversité le voici
dans son état actuel quatre grands
objectifs et pour les réaliser 22 cibles
à atteindre
première observation plus de 955
segments sont entre crochets sur 27
pages c'est 80% du texte
c'est ce sur quoi les pays ne se sont
pas encore entendus qui ne fait pas
consensus et quand on parle un sujet
aussi complexe que la biodiversité et
qu'est-ce qu'on doit faire on comprend
vite que la formulation est tout
parmi les quatre objectifs le premier
est le cœur du document prenons un
extrait à partir de maintenant ou pas
l'extinction causée par l'humain des
espèces alors lesquelles peut-être
toutes les espèces celles connues ou
menacées est arrêté pour 2030 ou 2050
parmi les 22 cibles la plus connue celle
du 30% des reprochées pour 2030 est
encore entre crochet
le chiffre est un entre parenthèses et
c'est de Globo et Z nation
comment on a lu le 30 % tout ça c'était
un dossier
pour certains crochets les pays doivent
encore définir leur ambition ces
politiques d'autres crochets sont plutôt
liés à l'interprétation de termes
scientifique effectivement
protégé
les mots sont importants car une fois la
corps signé les pays devront réaliser
ces objectifs mesurer leur progrès et
les rapporter
c'est Julien Campbell qui est en charge
d'assurer le suivi avec les parties une
fois l'entente signée
la cop14 a reconnu qu'un des problèmes
était notre capacité à faire le suivi
des progrès et des interventions
il est admis que le cadre mondial
précédent celui-ci à Haïti en 2010 en
partie échoué parce que ses objectifs
étaient peu chiffrés et aucune façon de
mesurer les progrès n'était définis
ça se reflète dans les rapports
nationaux les pays emploient beaucoup
d'approches différentes et c'est très
difficile pour nous d'obtenir un
portrait mondial
c'est pour ça que l'équipe de Gillian
Campbell développe un cadre mondial de
suivi qui sera aussi négociable une
façon commune de mesurer que tous les
pays devront adopter une liste de
mesures ce qu'on appelle des indicateurs
donc ce qu'on cherche à faire c'est de
créer une liste indicateurs relativement
simple implémenter ou les données sont
accessibles à tout le monde ou le
méthodologie scientifique est disponible
comme indicateur il faudra bien sûr
mesurer les risques d'extinction le
nombre d'espèces en péril mais ce n'est
pas suffisant
prenons l'objectif 6 qui cause en ce
moment problème réduire le taux
d'introduction des espèces invasives
d'au moins 50%. et leur impact de 75%.
comment allons-nous mesurer ses 50% et
ses 75% à partir des indicateurs dont
nous disposons si nous ne mesurons que
les événements d'introduction d'espèces
invasives nous n'aurons aucun moyen de
dire de combien nous réduisons leur
impact nous ne pourrons donc pas
commenter sur ces 75%. sans bon
indicateur difficile d'avoir un accord
chiffré fort
et que les parties développent un texte
justificatif avec leur propre
indicateurs
où voulez-vous supprimer le nombre
c'est en ce moment vivement discuté
après des mois d'échanges avec les
parties et les scientifiques le cadre de
suivi comprend à présent 40 indicateurs
principaux essentiels et sont
accompagnés de plus de 300 indicateurs
optionnels ce qui est important à savoir
c'est que la liste qu'on va choisir en
décembre ça va être une première liste
on va on va se mettre d'accord sur les
indicateurs mais on attend pendant 2023
un tout un travail avec des experts pour
raffiner le processus
c'est la fin de la rencontre il y a
encore la confusion sur les indicateurs
certains partis craignent qui en est
trop d'autres qui soient trop complexes
des décisions clés n'ont pas encore été
prises
[Musique]
à Montréal les négociateurs devront en
arriver un consensus retirez tous les
crochets parfois tu sais un peu décevant
parce que tout est entre parenthèses là
c'est tellement beau ce qui est là dans
cette page là un accord à
l'international pour la nature ça c'est
je pense qu'il faut communiquer la
positive qui est derrière ça
cet accord vise l'utilisation durable de
la biodiversité un aménagement du
territoire qui tient compte de ses
besoins il encourage une diminution du
gaspillage alimentaire des mesures
légales pour inciter les entreprises à
mieux agir pour la biodiversité et une
représentation diverses pour la prise de
décision qui inclut les peuples
autochtones
196 pays vont se mettre autour une table
pour dire non à la
l'effondrement de la nature oui on
souhaite quelque chose là quelque chose
très ambitieux mais si on arrive à faire
un grand pas vers ça c'est positif on
peut construire on peut bâtir sur ça